now that we're in 2020 the start of a
new decade some things have changed in
the laptop world and some things haven't
just like last year people are searching
for the perfect laptop to buy for their
needs and our purchasing recommendations
still haven't changed between the
MacBook Air and the MacBook Pro so
before we go through those
recommendations once again but with a
bit of updated information I first want
to go through what's changed since last
year and that's the price the
best-selling laptop in 2020 is the
MacBook Air
so that MacBook Air that Linus was
talking about was actually the legacy
2017 model with the super huge bezels
horribly outdated tn display outdated
specs but overall decent laptop and I
believe that there's one reason why it's
the best-selling laptop and that's
because it's the cheapest way to get a
MacBook currently on sale for only 750
dollars on Amazon now what all of those
people who bought it might not realize
is that the updated MacBook Air with a
much better display better design newer
specs bigger trackpad and more is also
available for just seven hundred and
fifty nine dollars renewed on Amazon yes
that's the 2018 MacBook Air with the
latest design for only around 750
dollars which is unheard of because the
retail price at launch was $1,100 now a
lot of people steer clear from her nude
models because they're not brand new but
for only 750 bucks that's a steal and
Plus Amazon gives you a 90 day money
back guarantee if you have any issues
with it which is much more than the
regular 30-day return policy but this
ordeal doesn't end there we actually
found a MacBook Pro renewed for even
cheaper
only seven hundred and forty dollars
however it's the 2017 dual-core model
not the latest 2019 quad-core that we
recommend for anyone doing creative work
on their laptop but on the plus side the
older model features physical keys
instead of the new touch bar which some
people prefer so now that we have that
knowledge of the prices let's get into
compare
the MacBook Air and the MacBook Pro in
2020 first off if you're gonna be buying
one of those renewed models keep in mind
that they're both dual core models so
performance should it be that different
between them and both of them should
still be a great choice but if you're
doing any kind of creative work I'm
talking Photoshop Lightroom video
editing programming working with Logic
Pro or anything else like that we fully
recommend going with the 2019 MacBook
Pro with the quad-core CPU this is going
to give you so much more performance in
fact the base model gives you the best
bang for the buck in terms of processor
performance for the cache even beating
out the 16 inch macbook pro now if you
don't really care that much about
performance and you just want a very
good reliable laptop the MacBook Air is
an excellent choice and it actually has
a few perks over the pro it's got 12
hours of battery life instead of 10 on
the pro the wedge shaped design slants
the keyboard downward for a more
comfortable typing experience it's more
portable weighing a quarter of a pound
less than the pro it gets physical
function keys which a lot of people like
over the touch bar and of course you
also get the gold color option which you
don't get on the pro now one thing to
keep in mind is that both of these
MacBooks feature the butterfly key
switches which have had issues in the
past so if you want to steer clear of
that we are expecting new models of
these laptops coming with an updated
keyboard possibly sometime this year but
there's no guarantees now on the other
hand the MacBook Pro of course does get
a few perks over the air like the larger
trackpad that's more convenient it gets
a brighter display with better color
accuracy for things like photo and video
editing it gets better quality speakers
and most importantly much better
performance so to sum up which of these
Mac looks you should buy if you do a lot
of typing you need the most battery life
you can get and you don't really care
about performance or any type of editing
or creative work then the MacBook Air is
going to be perfect for you and if you
want a bit more of a premium MacBook
with extra horsepower better speakers
better display or you do any
of creative work 100% absolutely choose
the MacBook Pro over-the-air and if you
want the best most powerful MacBook ever
made the newly redesigned 16 inch
MacBook Pro with the new magic keyboard
is a game changer with incredible
amounts of performance
we'll have our purchasing guide links to
the best deals on all of these Mac books
down in the description below and if you
want to see a deeper dive into the
MacBook Air versus the MacBook Pro watch
that video right over there and if
you're not already subscribed click that
circle above to do so right now thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]